♪ ♪
>> NEED TO BE AFRICAN-AMERICAN,
NOT PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT.
LET ME TELL YOU, NO, IT HAPPENS
ALL THE TIME.
IT'S TRUE.
NONAFRICAN-AMERICANS THINK
AFRICAN-AMERICANS ALL LOOK THE
SAME.
>> Laura: DID SHE JUST SAY
WHAT I THINK SHE SAID?
SHE IS INSISTING THAT DETROIT
POLICE ONLY HIRE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS FOR DOING WHAT
IS CALLED FACIAL RECOGNITION
ANALYSIS, BECAUSE WHITE PEOPLE
ARE SO RACIST THEY CAN'T TELL
ANYONE APART.
THAT DIDN'T SIT WELL WITH
DETROIT'S POLICE CHIEF WHO SAID
THIS.
>> WE WERE APPALLED WHEN SHE
MADE THAT STATEMENT.
THERE IS A DOUBLE STANDARD.
IF I HAD MADE THE EXACT SAME
COMMENT, THEY WOULD'VE BEEN
CALLING FOR MY RESIGNATION AND
SHE WOULD'VE BEEN LEADING THAT
CHARGE.
THAT'S A FACT.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW IS
CANDACE OWENS, AUTHOR OF "BLACK
OUT."
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST AND
ATTORNEY.
ALL RIGHT, DEFENDANT WHAT SHE
SAID THERE.
>> THERE ARE STATS OF THE
DEFENDANT THE BASIS FOR
INFORMATION, SO THERE'S
INFORMATION THAT SHOWS WHERE
FACIAL RECOGNITION TECHNOLOGY IS
CONCERNED THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE OF
THE SAME RACIAL DEMOGRAPHIC AS
THOSE THAT THEY ARE BEING ABLE
TO IDENTIFY SUPPOSED TO BE HIRED
TO IDENTIFY HAVE AN EASIER TIME
DISTINGUISHING BETWEEN PERSON
AND PERSON.
THAT MEANS THAT WHAT SHE'S
SAYING AND WHAT SHE SAID
ACTUALLY LATER WAS NO, I'M NOT
SAYING THAT NO WHITE PEOPLE
SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN DOING THIS
JOB IN THIS CRIME LAB.
I'M CONCERNED THAT THIS IS A
CITY WHERE THERE IS 80% PEOPLE
WHO ARE AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND
HERE THERE IS A 95% PEOPLE WHO
ARE CAUCASIAN DOING THE
RECOGNITION.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF DATA --
>> Laura: THE
DISPROPORTIONALITY.
>> IT'S AN ISSUE OF THE DATA.
IF THE DATA SAYS THAT ONE PERSON
CAN DO SOMETHING WITH MORE
ACCURACY THAN ANOTHER,
ESPECIALLY WHERE IDENTIFICATION
IS CONCERNED, FOR CRIME --
>> Laura: IF IT WAS AT THE
OTHER WAY.
DON'T TALK OVER ME.
IF IT WAS SAID THE OTHER WAY
AROUND, WIPERS AND SAYING
SOMETHING EVEN REMOTELY AKIN TO
THOSE EVEN IF THERE WERE STATS
ABOUT CERTAIN TYPE OF BEHAVIOR
OR GOOD BEHAVIOR, BAD BEHAVIOR,
YOU WOULD BE DECRIED AS RACIALLY
STEREOTYPING AND USING RACE AS A
BASIS FOR DECISION-MAKING, WHICH
IS WHAT I THOUGHT WE WERE TRYING
TO GET AWAY FROM AS A COUNTRY.
THAT IS, TO MAKE ABOUT THE
DOUBLE STANDARD THAT IS
APPALLING HERE.
IT'S BECAUSE THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT SHE SAID IT WAS
RACIST.
I'M GOING TO TAKE AN OPTIMISTIC
TAKE TO SAY THAT POLICE OFFICER
OR SPEAK OUT AND CALL IT RACIST
IS LARGELY DUE TO THE FACT THAT
THERE IS AN AWAKENING HAPPENING
IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY AND WE
ARE REALIZING THAT THE REAL
RACIST ARE DEMOCRATS.
I THINK THAT IS A POSITIVE SPIN
ON THAT.
YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT, IF ANY
PERSON SAID SOMETHING BASED ON
STATISTICS.
IF SOMEBODY SAID WE SHOULD ONLY
POLICE IN BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS
BECAUSE THEY COMMIT THE MAJORITY
OF CRIMES, WHICH BY STATISTICS
WOULD BE ACCURATE.
BLACK AMERICANS COMMIT OVER 15%
OF ALL THE HOMICIDES IN THE
NATION.
THAT FACT WILL BE CALLED RACIST.
WE SHOULD ONLY HAVE BLACK POLICE
OFFICERS BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
WHITE POLICE OFFICERS AND KILLED
WHEN THEY ARE COMMITTING MORE OF
THE HOMICIDES.
THAT FACT WOULD BE CONSIDERED
RACIST.
HER PROBLEM IS RACIST AND
INEXCUSABLE AND I'M REALLY HAPPY
THAT BLACK AMERICANS ARE
SPEAKING OUT AND SAYING I DON'T
CARE THAT SHE WAS ON THE OTHER
FOOT.
RACISM IS RACISM.
>> Laura: THE BLACK POLICE
OFFICER HIMSELF THAT HE WOULD BE
FIRED IF HE SAID SOMETHING AKIN
TO THAT.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS, WOW.
>> WHAT HE SAID WAS IF I HAD
SAID THAT, THEN I WOULD BE IN
TROUBLE MEANING HE CAN'T SPEAK
THE TRUTH WITHOUT GETTING IN
TROUBLE.
THIS CONGRESSWOMAN COULD.
WHEN WE HAVE DATA --
>> Laura: ARE WE SAYING WE
SHOULD DETERMINE RACIAL
COMPOSITION BY SAYING, WHEN IT
IS THE "MONIQUE" SHOW YOU CAN
INTERRUPT.
I'M ASKING A SERIOUS QUESTION,
IF STATS ALONE DETERMINE RACIAL
CLASSIFICATIONS, I THINK WE
WOULD BE GOING INTO NOT A GREAT
PLACE FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PEOPLE, STATS ALONE DETERMINING
RACIAL CLASSIFICATIONS.
>> IT'S NOT STATS ALONE BUT THAT
IS WHY I LAID OUT THE ONE-TWO
THREE EVENT.
STATS AND DATA SAY SOMETHING.
WE HAVE PEOPLE IN THE CRIME LAB
THAT MAKE UP A
DISPROPORTIONATE --
>> Laura: WE MADE THIS POINT.
THIS IS NOT ONLY TRAGIC, IS AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW THE LEFT'S
NARRATIVE IS POISONING THE MINDS
OF OUR KIDS.
WHAT HAPPENED IS A 12-YEAR-OLD
BLACK GIRL CLAIMED THAT THREE
WHITE BOYS PINNED HER TO THE
GROUND AND CUT HER DREADLOCKS
WITH SCISSORS.
OF THE FAMILY ADMITTED IT WASN'T
TRUE AND THEY ISSUED A HEARTFELT
APOLOGY.
TO BE CLEAR I DO NOT BLAME THE
CHILDREN.
THIS IS A CHILD.
I DO TAKE ISSUE WITH ADULTS WHO
TRIED TO USE THIS HOAX TO PUSH
THEIR AGENDA RIGHT OFF THE BAT
WITH NO INVESTIGATION LIKE THE
NAACP TRIED TO DO.
FIRST THEY TRIED TO COVER UP THE
HOAX CLAIMING THE FAMILY REACHED
A PRIVATE RESOLUTION WITH THE
SCHOOL.
NEXT THEY SAID IN A STATEMENT
THAT REGRETTABLY THE ASSAULT
TURNED OUT TO BE FALSE.
REGRETTABLY QUESTION REQUIRES
THAT REGRETTABLE?
WE SHOULD BE HAPPY SHE WASN'T
ASSAULTED.
CANDACE, WHY WITH      WITH THEN
CANDACE, WHY WITH      WITH THEA
CANDACE, WHY WITH      WITH THEP
CANDACE, WHY WITH      WITH THET
CANDACE, WHY WITH      WITH THEY
TO COVER THIS UP?
>> THE NAACP FUNDS OFF OF RATE H
>> THE NAACP FUNDS OFF OF RATE T
>> THE NAACP FUNDS OFF OF RATE E
AND RACE AND IT'S EMBARRASSING
BECAUSE IT IS REVEALING AN UGLY
TRUTH WHICH IS THAT VICTIMHOOD
HAS BEEN BECOME A VIRTUE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO THIS GIRL,
SHE IS BELIEVING A NARRATIVE
THAT IS BEING SPUN THAT BLACK
AMERICANS, WHAT THEY SHOULD
ASPIRE TO HIS VICTIMHOOD AND
THAT IS WHAT NEEDS TO BE TALKED
ABOUT AND THAT IS NOT A
NARRATIVE THAT THE NAACP EVER
WANTS TO BE TALKED ABOUT BECAUSE
THERE WOULD BE NO NEED FOR THEM
TO EXIST.
EXIST.
TO BE ONE VICTIM APOLOGY IS
SOMETHING WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT A
LOT ON THE SHOW, AND WHETHER
IT'S A WHITE PERSON
CLAIMING THAT HE IS A VICTIM ORA
CLAIMING THAT HE IS A VICTIM ORB
CLAIMING THAT HE IS A VICTIM ORK
CLAIMING THAT HE IS A VICTIM ORP
CLAIMING THAT HE IS A VICTIM ORR
CLAIMING THAT HE IS A VICTIM OR-
CLAIMING THAT HE IS A VICTIM ORI
CLAIMING THAT HE IS A VICTIM ORN
CLAIMING THAT HE IS A VICTIM ORT
CLAIMING THAT HE IS A VICTIM ORI
CLAIMING THAT HE IS A VICTIM ORS
CASE THERE DOES SEEM TO BE THIS
NARRATIVE THAT IS FORWARDED A
LOT ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND EVEN
YOUNGER NOW.
KIDS WHO ARE YOUNGER.
MOST KIDS AREN'T EVEN PAYING
ATTENTION TO SKIN COLOR.
THEY ARE BEYOND THAT.
MY KIDS ARE PEER THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT THAT.
WHAT ABOUT THIS, MONIQUE?
[LAUGHTER]
WHAT DOES THIS TELL ABOUT US,
THE REACTION THAT PEOPLE WANT TO
BE IT'S TRUE ON THE LEFT AND
THEY ARE DISAPPOINTED WHEN IT IS
NOT TRUE.
>> WHAT MS. OWENS JUST SAID IS
THE MOST ABSURD AND SAD THING I
THINK I HAVE HEARD SINCE I'VE
BEEN APPEARING ON THE SHOW WITH
HER.
AFTER ALL THE TIMES THAT YOUNG
BLACK GIRLS HAVE GONE MISSING,
HAVE BEEN PROSTITUTED, HAVE BEEN
ENTERED INTO TRAFFICKING AND NO
ONE CARED.
NOT WHEN THEY WERE IN AFRICA,
NOT WHEN THEY WERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS ONE TIME WHEN THIS YOUNG
GIRL SAID SOMETHING HAPPENED TO
HER AND EVERYBODY JUMPED TO HER
DEFENSE AND BELIEVE HER I'M GLAD
THEY JUMPED TO HER DEFENSE, AND
I'M GLAD THEY BELIEVE HER.
I'M SORRY WHATEVER SHE WENT
THROUGH THAT LETTER TO THE POINT
THAT SHE SAID SOMETHING THAT WAS
NOT TRUE.
I AM SORRY THAT SHE SAID
SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT TRUE.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THOSE
THREE BOYS?
>> LIKE I JUST THAT, I'M SHE
SAID SOMETHING THAT WASN'T TRUE.
I'M SORRY THOSE THREE BOYS WERE
ACCUSED AND THEY WERE ACCUSED
AND HOW DID NOTHING WRONG.
WHEN I'M NOT SORRY ABOUT IS THAT
SHE WAS BELIEVED.
ARE WE REALLY NOW GOING TO BE IN
THIS PLACE, DON'T BELIEVE THE
VICTIMS IF THEY ARE BLACK GIRLS?
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT I SAID.
THIS IS TRULY BAD ACTING.
>> I'VE NEVER DONE THAT BEFORE.
>> OBVIOUSLY NOT.
WHAT I SAID AS I GENERALLY FEEL
BAD FOR THIS GIRL BECAUSE SHE IS
A PART OF A CULTURE OF LITERALLY
WHAT YOU JUST TO COME UP AND HAD
TO BE A VICTIM LIKE SUMMING
HAPPENED ON THE SHOW THAT YOU
WERE SO OUTRAGED ABOUT.